I climb up hella fast I was like this
I'm Ain no B I get up there I do the
technique and I look down and I'm like
oh Jesus
[Music]
Christ welcome back everybody to a
phenomenal episode of the careful boys
where we have merchandise by the way
check it out check it out Nick where's
yours of October check the link hurry up
Nick all right didn't want his BS you
didn't have to do that cool we have
subin in the house today what's up Sub
sub thank you guys what is something you
never thought you'd be able to do until
you actually did it [__] every oh wow
literally every archery what do you mean
everything yeah archery is the first
thing that came to your mind you thought
you would never be able to do it uh well
enough but you got the caiss vibe
already like it's so natural it almost
feels like you could pick one up and
just oh my God Bullseye do you have one
of those you have one of those modern
ones with like all the Neons and [__] no
I don't I don't do compound I do recurve
what's the difference hey C can I make a
can I can I say something you cannot no
I'm going to make a outside me and
Anthony were making fun of you calling
you uh no not making fun complimenting
complimenting we're calling you you do
look like action hero right now though
can you can you can you get a quick
strut for the camera so everybody you
look like straight up like we were
cracking jokes this is the black little
this is Natasha Romanov superhero come
on
come on you like a [__] superhero so
this is a compound B you're a [__]
superhero I typed in compound bow yeah
so that's a compound what's a recurve uh
recurve is like the original bow and
they're actually a little bit harder to
learn cuz you have to have a little bit
more technique to it oh it looks like an
Old School Compound you can get your
dials in um well I think you just grow
sticking [__]
yeah oh [__] recurve re yeah recurve is
like that what I want to do so like the
ballers in Japan they um they all do
horseback or archery that's pretty tight
that's cool but then they also wear the
outfit I would love like you wear the
[__] Samurai [__] yeah and you're
like I would love to learn how to do
archery on a horse I would love to do
that why do you say you didn't think you
could do archery and then you tried it
just cuz it just seemed a lot harder um
and to a degree it is like to be
consistent
so like your groupings have to be super
consistent for you to even say that you
did a good job you can't just hit the
the target a few times here and there
you want your groupings to be as close
as possible and as accurate as possible
across the board with how many arrows
that you do have so um it is a little
bit of a learning curve with recurve
just because of like your Technique your
body positions play a huge role in it um
how far the target is so stuff like that
um how windy it is the
weather so and I think the craziest
thing about archery is you're not even
looking like this you're look you're
just feeling like this really no you're
looking I thought you're
aiming you're definitely aiming are you
yeah but do you have like sights or how
what do you with a recurve you don't
with a compound you do have a sight
there's there's like [__] Crosshair
yeah with the compound it's more like um
but the compound you can actually put a
sight on oh but I did recurve too the OG
style yeah and then
it's and there's different there's
different weights to the to the bows too
I used to make them which ones recurves
yeah with chopsticks oh I made those too
tight and branches branches no
Chopsticks those are the best I'd be
like going on Hikes and [__] and you see
the perfect Branch that's like curved
they're like I'm taking this one H what
kind of string would you use shoa I
would I would take the elastic band out
of my mom's sewing kit and
then wait so Nick what were you making
fun of me about oh what were you saying
we were making fun of you dude we just
said you look like a superhero that's
all cool thanks wait we should do a a JK
Adventure forse back riding art treat or
do we do art yeah let's so we could see
your skills that would be cool so much
Friendly Fire like oh [__] that's so
dangerous shooting ones revolvers yeah
have you seen those cowboys
so cool that's wild so sick dude
horseback riding in general is [__]
cool it is it's scary bro it's scary as
[__] it's scary youever see yeah dude do
what in Hawaii I just did last week for
Hannah's birthday oh brownie got you to
hook up we went to
Gunstock oh ask brownie his homie would
just put you in the back of someone's
Random House what I should have asked
him no cuz they didn't let us Trot they
didn't let us like like run faster no it
was just a walk I was like man I could
have been on a [__] donkey yeah
brownie homie is just so Random you go
into someone's backyard and then boom
it's just big big the whole Mountain wow
[__] everywhere I want to get more
into that though I feel like a lot of
things people just have to like first
see themselves be able to do it like
that belief part A lot of it is just if
you think about everything like if you
want to achieve something it's just a
broken down skill you know what I mean
like being a painter or like there's no
like magic it's like the fundamentals
all at this point for everything it's
broken down into small steps right it's
like if you want to be a black building
Jiu-Jitsu it's like do you have to be a
genius at it no like it's achievable if
you break down the steps stick with it
and then over time you get there I think
you just have to be okay with sucking at
something new for a little bit yeah yeah
I think that's the big thing and
sticking to it and sticking to it and
being taking the L's knowing that this
is okay to suck at because this is new
and I just have to get over this
threshold of sucking at this for x
amount of time before I get get cuz you
anytime you start something you always
want to quit immediately because there's
the ego involved in it like the ego and
immediately you know what I actually I
really like the beginner phas where I
don't know [__] and I'm not good at it
but like when I start to get some skill
in it I get too serious or like you know
what I mean like it gets to this weird
hump where like it means too much to you
is that what it is um it's not enjoying
it's more like work now or maybe fall
back on like I'm just a beginner maybe
yeah but mindset I always feel like at
there yeah it's just weird at the
beginning for me it feels like a lot
more work always and that's fine but
once you kind of get the hang of it then
it feels like like oh I could have more
fun with this I could have more
creativity in it but usually when you
start anything for me it's always like
this is hard but it's I have to tell
myself like all the time like this is
hard but it's okay you know I think it's
good to humble yourself with new new
skills you got to eat pile of [__] I
love new skills being being like at the
very bottom of a learning curb is
actually [__] healthy and awesome
because you only have somewhere up to go
especially for especially in your like
later years of adulthood and stuff where
you feel like you're supposed to be good
at this and you start feeling all
[__] self-conscious about things
whether it be your career your
relationship whatever like being at the
[__] bottom of the barrel sometimes
is the exact thing that you need to just
be like ah there's still stuff to do
there's still stuff to learn and there's
like a humility to it that makes it
amazing I remember um oh dude I remember
my [__] prob I've never had this
feeling with any other thing ever in
terms of trying to learn to do something
but I remember trying to learn how to do
windmills when I was in college yeah
yeah yeah and it took me [__] in 4
and 1/2 months so like 4 and 1/2 months
you know that's what people sometimes
say but it feels [__] forever how
come Filipinos get in like 3 days yeah
what's up with that hey do Filipinos get
in 3 days hell no thank you all the
Filipinos I you got in like 3 days anime
they they meant three years so so
windmills is [__] hard to learn K's
still learning them right now too right
the point is like you're physically
throwing your body in in a in in ways
that you're just like I you have to like
understand your own physics your
momentum your strength like the grace
the fitness all of that but you're just
hurting yourself and you're putting
bruises on your body and you're just
doing this and then everybody around you
who [__] has it you just feel so like
okay uh it's possible so I'm just going
to keep going but it takes months and I
remember the very first time I got
continuous windmills I was at the
recreation center at UCI and I was by
myself it was just like we just did a
workout and I was just like H the the
the [__] Fitness room is empty I'm
just going to go try on the mats right
so I go in there and I hit [__]
continuous swim Mills for the first time
I was so hyped I was jumping up and down
the room by myself I called my sister
wow I stra had to call cuz I was like I
don't know who's going to pick up the
phone I had to call her and she's not
even someone who usually like in she she
if anything she's like that like uh that
random back door like you only hit her
up if it's like the most incredible or
the most painful things that you ever go
through I just didn't normally think of
but she was like I have to tell somebody
and and she was the first person I
thought of and I called her and I'm on
the phone I'm [__] hyp I'm like you
believe this I got Contin she like
doesn't give a [__] but I got continuous
windmills and I just remember that
feeling being like I never would have
thought I could do this and it was just
super super powerful but I've never
actually had that feeling ever again
something that powerful thought you were
going to say like I never did them ever
again after that I was like and that's
when I quit windmills I do I do that
when I'm drunk I only do when I'm drunk
the most powerful feeling like that that
I ever felt was uh in boot camp so in
boot camp like um I was trying trying to
like crush it as hard as I can cuz I
suck really bad in school today's video
is brought to you by Uncommon Goods are
you looking for holiday gifts cuz if
you're a good family member and friend
of course you are but you don't want to
get the same boring stuff nope you want
to get something uncommon and good such
as this kit right here they sent us the
Mochi donut kit and how did they know we
love Mochi Donuts we always eat it in
every single time we shoot JK JK we get
it but now we get to make it with the
friends at home and what's awesome is
they have a lot of unique gifts just
like this that are made by small
Artisans local peoples just straight up
not these big old manufacturing
companies but just you know homegrown
grassroot tights yeah so who do you want
to support this holiday season Jeff
Bezos or Morimoto son like this one Mr
Morimoto
to get 15% off your next gift go to
uncommongoods.com sloff thee that's
uncommongoods.com off the record for 15%
off don't miss out on this limited time
offer Uncommon Goods we're all out of
the orinary you think TSA would let us
through with this bag they
should Uncommon Goods and then so I did
pretty good I got appointed a squad
leader so you're kind of in charge of
like maybe like 20 people in your
squad and uh and most of the there's
only four Squad leaders in a platoon so
in the platoon like most people kind of
looked up to me for leadership and we
got to this thing where it's called The
Stairway to Heaven if you guys ever
drive by Camp Pendleton on the five
freeway you'll see this giant [__]
ladder that's like I don't know 100 ft
tall and each rung is like four or 5T
above the other one so if you're
standing here there's like a big ass log
the first log goes across like right
here the next one is like another four 5
ft and I remember the drill instructor
going to this thing and there's no
nothing to attach to and the drill
instructor goes who here is scared of
heights I was like the first one I I had
no shame and then he looked at me like
what the [__] one of my squad leaders
like get the [__] over here quanz they
made him look bad I was like this
recruit's scared of heights sir and cuz
I think the people that are scared of
heights he wanted to rush them through
first because they're going to take
[__] forever so there's a specific
technique where it's where the logs meet
you kind of like reach over like with
your arm and then you kind of like hook
the other log and once you do this you
can hang your legs over and then you can
unhook your arm and then kind of rinse
and repeat and go up the thing is
um once you lock your arms in this thing
technically you can't fall out so it t
it allows you to swing your legs over
but it takes a little bit of leap of
faith so when it was my turn to go up
I'm like all right [__] this I don't be
no [__] [__] I don't want to be a
[__] so I climb up hella fast you go
all the way up but then on the way down
is where the leap of faith happens cuz
you're like this and you have to kind of
like UNS swing your legs and then when
you UNS the log you kind of just drop oh
[__] and then you just have to trust
that the you believe in this technique
and it you're like oh [__] what the [__]
and your legs are dangling and you're
like 80 ft in the air and you're like
this 80 ft so I'm up there I I climb up
hella fast I was like man [__] this [__]
I'm [__] I Ain no [__] I get up
there I do the technique and I look down
and I'm like oh Jesus [__]
Christ and then the children get the
[__] down Guan what the [__] are you
doing up there and you just see and on
the bottom is just [__] wood chips
like [__] like you know bark like
like it's going to [__] prevent any
death like you'll just die you know and
I was like oh [__] this is time for me
to go this is time for me to go [__] I
don't give a [__] so I went like this I
let go of my legs and I swing and you
feel that moment of weightlessness and I
was like
oh and I'm like oh [__] this is [__]
crazy and then then everything became
easy because you just know that feeling
and that was like that moment I'll
Always Forever remember cuz it was
something that it took a leap of faith
to do and then the consequence I think
would have just been death or I same
with windmills you know you could just
die or or or you're just there and
you're probably be like somebody called
that1 I catch it
down I feel like in the situation you're
forced to do the first not the latter of
being like someone called 911 cuz like
everybody there in that environment
you're just like I have only one option
either die or do it yeah and looking at
it in the other way I think they should
make the scared people go last cuz if
you watch other people do it you feel
like okay we do it yeah I'm like why you
making the [__] scaredy-cats go first
cuz it teaches you the most probably
does but then maybe everybody who
thought they could do it is like maybe I
can't can't do it but now I look like a
[__] in front of 80
people it's all about the
lesson yeah break dancing was one of the
only moments right I felt like that
windmills was one of them air flares
yeah really D I can even imagine getting
your first air flare that's [__]
you're just flying and hoping to not die
yeah you catch it you're floating you're
like what the [__] I'm one of those
Asians
break break dancing is hard though like
I feel like every guy
at one point tried break dancing
especially your Asian yeah yeah like I
tried I didn't [__] go anywhere with
it and I was like I'll just start
popping you know what I mean like it's
just uh I think choreography is super
hard lot people a lot of people try and
they never pass that level of being able
to do power moves yeah yeah you can only
you have to be young if you're if you're
if someone came up to me at 2530 said
I'm going to start break dancing I would
have told him stop really really flavor
or just flavor all foot work flavor not
even flavor bro you too late you late
kids are getting flavor like these kids
now are in
crazy kids now years it's too old to
start break dancing at 25 you late to be
like a killer in the game absolutely H
you late you're going to be like I got
my windmills you're going be like bro
you mad late I can do 1990s cuz dude
we're in 2020 right now right like
8-year-old got [__] 2,000 of those
you late dog get out of here bro I would
have said choreography or popping or
freestyling but choreography I think is
hard you got to count and remember your
moves 5 six seven8 and one like come on
that's hard and you got to listen just
like a air flare
no air flare you just throw
it I think one one thing that's like
something that I'm like oh while I
surpassed or I never would have believed
is sometimes I just wake up and the
first thing I'm thinking in the morning
is like [__] this [__] how like
yesterday I was like I don't know if I
can make it as a
YouTuber or like can I you know and then
I'm just it felt like I just was that
20-year-old in college and I'm like I
want to make funny videos on YouTube and
then like that was me yesterday and I
woke up fast forward I did all that and
now I'm like damn that [__] really
happened and I think that's really a
weird feeling I get right when I wake up
and it's fresh in my mind as if it was
like I was a college student last night
and I woke up today and I did it and
then that's I think that's one of the
like it's like I don't know maybe that
is a part of like this whole impostor
syndrome that people talk about but and
now I'm like what's weird to me is is it
kind of like you're in disbelief of
everything you've already done you're
like wow I did all that or all that
happened or yeah and I'm still shooting
goals and doing it like my head is
saying okay I want to live in multiple
cities and I want to open up a business
with my friends in Hawaii and I'll live
there for a little bit cuz I've been
thinking about it for so long since we
been visiting our friends and family
right so it's like it's a lot of people
talk about for decades like hey one day
let's open up a surf school together
yeah we'll do it right and then you
actually do it and I'm I'm like that's
kind of the cool thing is like oh yeah
we did it and then what's the next thing
we can do so then my mind now turns into
this like how many other things can we
go to and now there's more dreams than
there is time to do it yeah which is a
crazy feeling
where that fresh College mind is is
still like right there like that feeling
and that memory of Hope is still there
so it just doesn't feel that far away
you know what I mean it doesn't feel
like I I came so far from there it came
it it really feels like wow that that
I'm living it and I was dreaming it
and it's it's not that I didn't what's
the word it's kind of like you have the
Hope early on but when you actually do
it it's nothing like you imagined yeah
it's usually not yeah yeah it's not and
sometimes it's good sometimes it's bad
right so sometimes you like dream of
something and then you get there and
you're like oh [__] this is whack yeah
but I think that's the craziest thing is
um I think in the very beginning you
just hope for something and you try your
best and then you get there but then
after you keep doing this over and over
again it's just this crazy
reality of not so much what if but like
when and
how yeah m
he